you guys love the spoilers right
whose bright idea was it to send actors
on tours to promote the show and tell
them they're not allowed to talk about
the show what a scam well sometimes the
actors just let things slip ready to
find out who's the worst at keeping
secrets i'm gonna just say four rumors
about this season and then i want to see
your reaction number one uncomfy
contacts means one thing vecna during
netflix's official on the set of
stranger things video caleb mclaughlin
who plays lucas sinclair showed gate and
matarazzo a photo on his phone oh man
did they put contacts in you yeah were
they uncomfy yeah well usually contacts
wouldn't be a big deal caleb isn't one
to wear them for his character and this
season all of the contacts seem to be
associated with possession by vechna so
if that's not a spoiler we don't know
what is
number two all harnessed up with nowhere
to run after what happened with sadie
sync in the first half of season four we
can't help but feel that this post is a
major spoiler couldn't the selfie wait
noah of course there could be other
stunts in part two but we are skeptical
theory maybe vecna will go after all of
them at once and in a race to beat the
clock quite literally millie must stop
vecna to save her friends not a bad
theory right number three surely an
explosion is an innocent spoiler right
right out of fear of spoiling anything
again noah took down a photo of an
explosion taken while filming part two
of season four we're sure it's some sort
of spoiler when people were like is this
a spoiler and i was like oh my god i'm
gonna get in trouble but hey once it's
on the internet good luck taking it down
right
number four darn it gayton you're lucky
you were just so adorable or we might
have been angrier about this gate and
madorazo spoiled season 4's ending way
back in 2016. so the monster was a
recent test subject
number five at least finn didn't leak
hopper survival like netflix did while
it might not be a big spoiler it sure is
a season 4 spoiler of some description
we find out what happened to hopper this
season
okay number six honestly we were
grateful for the emotional preparation
that noah gave us he spoiled the death
of the dog in season three will's dog
chester i think he died didn't we
he did
number seven we've got confirmation for
returning characters in season five
joseph quinn may have just spoiled the
fate of his character eddie munson
hoping for a pair-up between him and
charlie heaton's character jonathan
byers for season 5. and we doubt since
these two don't really know each other
that they could just be doing a cameo as
one of vecna's nightmare threats like
billy with max hey it could be a red
herring too who knows number eight it
would be a long season if these two
didn't see each other mike and eleven
are they going to reunite
is this a spoiler once again it can
probably just be assumed this was going
to happen but hey half our cast wound up
in utah so
anything is possible number nine
surprise this season they're in a mall
shocking
noah spoiled the awesome location they
were filming at for season three
the look on his face when he realized is
just priceless too yes noah is the one
who just can't keep the secrets to
himself he's called the tom holland of
stranger things by his co-stars because
he spoils so much
number 10 this is why only young people
are allowed on instagram david harbor
went on instagram live and promised fans
he'd read an excerpt of his script from
stranger things millie was watching
go back to work did she ever sass him
hard oh no millie don't tell netflix no
real spoilers were given although he did
pop up in his television makeup not that
that was any surprise given it was
already in the trailer it's still
problematic to go live on set in costume
though highly do not recommend who knows
what could happen i'm just gonna read
your sections of the script
number eleven is it a spoiler or is he
playing a terrible poker face will we
see eleven get her powers back
but
yeah
number 12 netflix you should know better
really sometimes netflix can be just as
bad as the actors they put strict ndas
on first off they spoiled the fate of
hopper in their trailer for season four
second because of course part one ended
on a cliffhanger with nancy in the
clutches of vecna well not his creepy
left hand but you know possessed knowing
what we know about how this all works
though the clock could be ticking
towards her doomsday so is it really a
spoiler
well it doesn't seem like any of the
stranger things actors have dethroned
the king of spoilers yet let's not
forget that tom holland literally
spoiled the biggest character demise in
all of the mcu maybe a young gayton
comes close do you think nancy dyer will
make it out alive let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things